[Music]
from a production company that sounds
like they make porn comes a film with
the same production value as porn in the
low-budget hit that transformed the
horror genre into straight-up torture
porn
saw seesaw a great idea for a student
short film that somehow got stretched
into six feature-length sequels to video
games and one super fun roller coaster
when two strangers wake up in your
typical Taco Bell bathroom the only way
out is to patiently use the various
sauce slabs and guns to weaken their
chains until they're able to break free
but instead of the obvious prepare for a
hundred minutes of reminiscing partner
how I gotta play catch
[Music]
and dramatically reaching for stuff
[Applause]
almost have another idea
nope tremble before the jigsaw killer a
psychopath who combines the traps of
wily coyote with the terrifying puppetry
of Jeff Dunham come saw and conquer the
first in a long line of cheaply made
pornos featuring the cost rofl yeah of
being trapped in a room because there
wasn't the budget for more occasions the
panic of the fast-paced editing
because there wasn't the budget for
better effects and the cringe factor of
watching the movie screenwriter tried to
act lords calm down there must be a way
out because there wasn't the budget for
professional actors so settle in for the
one that started it all full of cool
well thought out traps that the sequels
turned into complete parodies of
themselves you must press both buttons
at once in the box but for you however
in doing so you appear as a sacrifice of
her own to can live for will die this
guy talking about and horrific violence
happening off screen that the sequels
turned into the star of the franchise
girl watches this stuff oh go to
starring go to starring starring Kristen
Bell Robin Hood man chain dental plan
Lisa needs braces awesome mix ball you
won rush hour this guy the bad guy from
lost I think she's on parenthood Phil
and Cher
saw one you saw them all hey at least
it's not a found footage movie be sure
to subscribe for more honest trailers
dude I'm not your bro who does number
two work for I'm directly below the
enemy scrotum what seems to be the
officer problem
Fowler Magoo Lewis